it's my high honor to present the Award
for Best Actress in a leading role no
writer director or producer would have
anyone to blame if he had any of these
fine ladies starring in his film the
nominees are for her hilarious depiction
of a woman who passes herself off as a
man pretending to be a woman Julie
Andrews in victor/victoria
for her riveting portrayal of the
beautiful but tortured actress whose
star was a comet that burned out too
soon
Jessica Lange in France
for her compelling realism as a
frustrated wife caught between
revolution and bureaucracy [ __ ] Spacek
and Missy
for her astonishing versatility and
bringing William Styron's victims from
the printed page to the screen Meryl
Streep and Sophie's Choice
the whole beguiling honesty as the
winsome factory worker who makes a
gentleman out of an officer Debra Winger
no matter what the decision they've all
made film history I commend you all and
the winner is marvelous Meryl speech
kids just be too
it is oh boy no matter how much you try
to UM imagine what this is like it's
just so incredibly thrilling right down
to your toes I have a lot of people to
thank and I'm gonna be one of those
people that tries to mention a lot of
names because I know just two seconds
ago my mother and father went completely
berserk and I'd like to give some other
mothers and fathers that opportunity I'd
like to thank william Styron for
creating this beautiful character and
for and Alan Pakula for bringing it to
the stage and allowing me to play it I
would like to thank Marty starter and
ITC for finding the financing for it
nestor almond rose the great
cinematographer albert Walski wonderful
costumer and the crew tommy Priestley
the Gerardo's the Dubois brothers Tommy
Prague Chris Newman Danny Maitland Wally
props lillian alba dixie roy halen i'd
like to thank my polish coach elena Baco
my german coaches and cataneo and David
Friedman and the 37 members of the
American and European casts whom I won't
mention all of their names but but for
two I feel like I owe them this because
everything that I had I got from looking
in their eyes and for the the great love
they gave me for five months I thank
Kevin Klein and Peter McNichol
and I thank you all very much
you